التجارب النوويه التي تجريها كوريا
الشماليه تهدد صحه وحياه مواطنيها وكذلك
مواطني الدول المجاوره وفق منظمات حقوقيه
بين عامي 2006
2017 اجرت سته تجارب نوويه خطيره في منشات
الشماليه التي تكثر الى جانبها زراعه
وانواع متعدده من الفطر وبحسب المنظمات
نفسها مئات الالاف من الاشخاص يعيشون قرب
منشاه بونغيري هم معرضون لخطر الاشعاعات
التي تتسرب للمياه الجوفيه المستخدمه في
الشرب والري ايضا العلماء حذروا من تسرب
الاشعاع من انفاق الاختبار تحت جبل مانتاب
مع تداولي تقارير عن موت الغطاء النباتي
هناك وولاده اطفال بعيوب خلقيه هذا
واكتشفت سول عام 2015 احتواء فطر القنفذ
والمستورد من كوريا الشماليه لاكثر من
تسعه اعضاف المستوى القياسي لنظائر
السيزيوم المشعم كما ان ذلك النوع من
الفطر الغالي وصل الى اليابان دون ان تعرف
انه قادم من كوريا الشماليه وكان يصدر على
انه منتج صيني
[موسيقى]